I used to have really punishing stage
frights I would throw up every time
before I went on stage and then I would
start getting panic attacks it's like
these demons that are in my head
like these voices that like me
that ruin everything like what is the
worst thing that they could experience
like what is the worst thing and then I
figured out it would be to do like a
monologue on stage where I'm like just
me nothing and I was like okay I'm I'm
going to do that that's where everything
changed and I found a way to like create
real
confidence by facing my fears and going
going at it head on and it also became
sort of a metric of how I've dealt with
difficult times ahead to run towards
them yeah to face it and to like
challenge it and it's like okay let's
watch this